a
[Música]
ah
el sector cultural ha sido de los más
golpeados durante esta pandemia con
decenas de festivales y conciertos
cancelados y además del cierre temporal
de teatros y museos sin embargo la isla
de guernsey en el canal de la mancha
presume de ser el único territorio en
europa de haber realizado un concierto
al aire libre con miles de personas y
sin medidas sanitarias la razón es muy
sencilla la isla de guernsey de apenas
70 kilómetros cuadrados está libre de
kobe 19 desde el pasado mes de mayo y
por eso tres mil personas se dieron cita
el pasado lunes en un festival de 12
horas de música continua no se puede
decir lo mismo de otros festivales como
el famoso glastonbury que tuvo que ser
pospuesto hasta el próximo año debido a
la pandemia y es que la cultura y las
industrias creativas generan 1 de cada 6
empleos tan sólo aquí en la ciudad de
londres además de que generan
de 52 mil millones de libras al año
[Música]
uno de los eventos más esperados aquí en
eeuu
todos los años es el festival de burning
man que se celebra en el desierto de
nevada en blackrock todos los años desde
1986 es un festival bohemio al aire
libre donde al final se quema una
especie de efigie enorme este año ha
tenido que ser debido a la pandemia
claro a través de internet y de la
realidad virtual el año pasado acudieron
casi 80 mil asistentes al evento en
persona este año todavía se desconoce
cuánta gente está acudiendo a través de
internet y de la realidad virtual muchos
acusan de hecho a este festival que
convenció siendo una especie de quedada
bohemia para gente de california que
está convirtiendo ahora mismo en un
festival mucho más mediático que bohemio
ahora también otro evento cultural muy
conocido en eeuu la mayor feria de
coches de autos vintage y de lujo que se
llaman concours d'elegance que se
celebra todos los años desde hace casi
100 años en santa cruz este año ha
tenido que ser cancelado ni siquiera
puede tener nada a través de internet
realidad virtual miles de aficionados a
los autos vintage y de lujo se han
quedado este año sin poder acudir
[Música]
intensas medidas de seguridad sanitaria
enmarcan la mostra de venecia el primer
festival internacional de cine que se
celebra en medio de la pandemia para
evitar contagios un importante
dispositivo sanitario ha sido previsto
con controles de temperatura en cada
entrada distanciamiento social
obligatorio uso de las mascarillas
inclusive dentro de las salas de
proyección también se prevén exámenes de
coronavirus para los participantes que
llegan de países de fuera de europa las
concentraciones de personas están
prohibidas inclusive en el tapete rojo
en el cual el número de fotógrafos ha
sido limitado este año y el público no
tiene acceso para ir a pedir autógrafos
[Música]